facebook und google haben leichtes spiel
wer auf den plattformen daten
hinterlässt der gibt freiwillig
informationen preis die unternehmen
können sie nutzen und mit ihrer hilfe
werbung generieren
doch gehören ihnen deshalb die daten
zumindest in der eu gibt es ein neues
gesetz eigentümer bleiben die user doch
müssten die dann nicht auch mitverdienen
das deutsch amerikanische startup day
ballett hat dafür ein geschäftsmodell
entwickelt die user bekommen einen
anteil wenn ihre daten verkauft werden
wenn wir in fünf bis zehn jahren
zurückblicken wird uns das heute
vorkommen wie das finstere mittelalter
der daten als wir keinerlei kontrolle
hatten und im grunde jeder unsere daten
beanspruchen konnte und die keinen
einfluss darauf hatten
in zukunft werden daten eines der
wichtigsten güter für menschen sein und
auch eine einnahmequelle von der sie
leben können
außerhalb der eu gelten weniger strenge
datenschutzgesetze zum beispiel in den
usa
in vielen ländern gibt es überhaupt
keine regelungen data wallet will daten
bündeln und die user selbst entscheiden
lassen wer sie nutzen darf denn die
datenmenge ist riesig soziale netzwerke
sammeln kommentare statusmeldungen likes
und sie können daraus emotionen ablesen
informationen kommen auf hochgeladenen
fotos online shops sammeln informationen
über unsere einkaufs vorlieben und
unseren lebensstil
wer sich bei partnerbörsen oder online
foren anmeldet gibt seine einstellungen
preis der rabattkarten nutzt teilten mit
wie viel geld er ausgibt
doch richtig lukrativ wird es erst wenn
die datenflut aufbereitet wird
das übernehmen so genannte daten broker
sie kaufen die daten auf und versuchen
mit hilfe von big data analysen
zusammenhänge herzustellen
daraus entsteht eine art digitaler
steckbrief
mein profil beschreibt einen menschen
beschreibt ängste beschreibt bedürfnisse
beschreibt vielleicht eine finanzielle
lage um entsprechend werbung auch auf
den geldbeutel zugeschnittenen schalten
zu können beschreibt uns so gut wie ist
selbst unsere besten freunde kommen
könnten
karsten nohl ist spezialist für
datensicherheit seine firma berät
unternehmen den globalen datenhandel
sieht er kritisch denn es ist ein
milliardengeschäft allerdings nur für
wenige google allein als eine firma
verdient im jahr über 100 milliarden
dollar
mit geschaltete werbung diese 100
milliarden dollar müssen natürlich auch
wieder reingeholt werden durch produkte
die dann auf basis dieser werbung
geschaltet werden das heißt eine
einzelne firma verdient an jedem nutzer
hunderte bis tausende dollar pro jahr
data wolle dreht nun den spieß um
über die webseite der firma können die
user ihre daten selbst verwalten und
bekommen einen anteil beim verkauf ihrer
daten
noch ist data wolle zu klein um facebook
oder google gefährlich zu werden dass
die giganten daten sammeln können sie
nicht verhindern
doch sie wollen fairness
im grunde bieten wir den leuten an all
ihre daten die sie im internet erzeugt
haben auf sämtlichen plattformen die sie
nutzen in ein profil zu speichern und
sie dann mit den firmen zu teilen die
sie gut finden
wer einen daten profil bei uns hat kann
es an eine firma oder auch an 50
verkaufen was data wallet vor hat ist
visionär ein eigentumsrecht an den
eigenen daten und die möglichkeit an
ihnen mitzuverdienen
[Musik]